ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Samuel
Le come in with nothing and we're going
to come out with nothing our short life
here on Earth is just a glimpse hi just
listen to Samu Le's presentation has
been fantastic five key point to to
success Financial Freedom you need to
get his film bless you see you soon this
is probably the best presentation I've
ever heard second time we've had Samuel
speak at one of our conferences he was
excellent last time and he was excellent
this time bring him along because he's
got great knowledge um and he presents
in a really humorous way our guys were
really
engaged I was really impressed with the
amazing value and content Samuel gave
across the bill so really great speaker
listen to what he's got to
say